[Musique]
ange lavenaire bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous les marigots tech et m'écoutent
candidat de second tour aux municipales
pour la ville de marigot où le taux de
participation pour le premier tour a été
de 55 points 57%
c'est joseph perez le maire sortant qui
est donc en tête à l'issue de ce premier
tour avec 49 points 47% des suffrages
exprimés soit 848 voix et vous vous êtes
en oz deuxième ange lavenaire à la tête
de la liste union pour la promotion de
l'animation de marigot vous avez
recueilli 434 voix 25 points 32% des
suffrages et nous avons affaire à une
triangulaire puisque monsieur bredas
également est candidat pour ce second
tour il y avait daniel gros désir au
premier tour mais il a recueilli 5,5
pour cent des suffrages et donc il a été
éliminé en jeu l'avenir 414 voix d'écart
dans un second tour en triangulaire
puisque c'est bien cette distance 1 que
vous avez avec le maire sortant joseph
peyras est-ce que c'est rédhibitoire
pour retrouver une fonction de maire
pour vous pas du tout
aujourd'hui il faut mobiliser les
acteurs ont fait le point et réellement
nous électeurs n'ont pas voté diverses
régions mais nous on va les faire voter
et on a à l'époque où nous sommes et à
la remontée n'da on y va mais il a fait
le double un de vos de vous voir oui je
m'élance arrêt de bus mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr on va rattraper cela alors
patrick bredas l'autre adversaire du
triangle avant ce que vous n'avez pas
voulu passer une alliance il vous aurait
sollicité au vous aurait fait comprendre
qu'il serait d'accord pour vous alliez
mais que vous n'auriez pas voulu car
vous seriez dit-il patrick bredas animé
par une seule chose au mobile et par une
revanche personnelle sur la défaite de
c'est une facilité de langage qui
coupable tout simplement monsieur pat et
good as veut table cohade evora si il
veut être tête de liste n'est pas sorti
deuxième lui a expliqué pas a + b que la
démocratie c'est pas ça donc il y avait
trop de prétentions en quelque sorte par
rapport à son score
c'est ce que vous voulez directement
il suffisait qu'il accepte simplement de
s'allier nous sans prétention comme
l'ont fait avec vous étiez prêt à lui
donner un poste d'adjoint peut-être une
délégation importante
les propositions qu'il a faites et elles
étaient pacsées
nous avons fait une contre proposition
il devait me répondre jusqu'à présent
j'ai pas de réponse alors on va voir
mais cette triangulaire peut-être
qu'elle va faciliter favoriser la
réélection de monsieur payrastre nous en
attendrait ce cas prendre
nous en avons conscience mais monsieur
bredas on retiendra l'histoire que
monsieur brida seront rassurés
l'élection 2014 de monsieur père est il
l'aura confirmé aux avenières pour
terminer comment s'annonce la phase de
second tour à marigot en particulier
sentez-vous un début de regain d'intérêt
pour l'élection municipale
et puis vous comment vous faites
campagne comment vous allez faire
campagne c'est ces prochains jours
oui nous avons une situation
particulière situation particulière et
évidemment on doit mettre des
dispositions particulières c'est vrai
que nous travaillons nous avons fait le
point sur l'électorat
aujourd'hui nous savons que nous avons
une réserve de voix importantes donc par
conséquent et nous on considère qu'il
est possible de remonter ce pas cet
écart de voix
nous allons utiliser tous les moyens
aujourd'hui qui sont disponibles les
réseaux sociaux et puis aussi que le
démarchage en respectant les règles
merci aux lavenère d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
on a l'impression que vous êtes assez
confiant oui mais on ne perd pas au
combat si on n'est pas confiant c'est
pas la peine d'y aller ça oukadi
spéciale le second tour d'élections
municipales réalisé par adel le doubs
bonne journée